à regarder leurs visages on les croirait
presque encore en vacances l'heure de la
rentrée a pourtant sonné pour les 120
élèves de l'école primaire francis
poulenc de guyancourt retrouvailles avec
les camarades histoire des vacances et
pour les plus sérieux déjà le travail
lorenzo dix ans un seul objectif en tête
la sixième bah on commence à parler de
nos vacances mais retrait quand on doit
se mettre au travail on s'y met c'est ma
dernière année et au et après je vais
commencer à bien travailler pour après
passé en en sixième les enseignants font
connaissance avec leur classe et les
nouveautés de la rentrée
madame savoie et professeurs des écoles
ans et eu un réel partage cette année
ses heures de cours avec une collègue
chaque classe est différente et cette
année je n'ai pas eu ces 20 depuis un
certain temps donc effectivement c'est
pour moi c'est aussi un renouveau tout à
fait de maîtresses et plus on est plus
on est plus exigeante au fait envers eux
étant de maîtresses et je vois pas pour
être honnête je vois pas d'inconvénient
la rentrée une journée particulière
également pour la directrice de l'école
compte et j'irai dispatcher des missions
qui peuvent s'avérer compliqué lorsqu'on
découvre un nouvel établissement et a
été déjà directrice deux ans dans une
deuxième école que je connaissais ça a
été là c'est une ville que je ne connais
pas une école que je ne connais pas donc
ça ajoute du stress mais j'étais
tellement bien accueilli
non ça s'est bien passé lorsqu'on arrive
dans une école il faut pas tout
bouleverser ça vous faire cela les
enseignantes ça a bouleversé les enfants
et je pense que s'il ya déjà des choses
qui ont été mis en place et qui
fonctionne il faut toujours les faire
perdurer
élèves enseignants et direction devront
désormais attendre le 19 octobre
prochain pour souffler à nouveau ce sera
alors le début des vacances de la
toussaint